Darcy I'm such a fan this is such a
moment for me
what about the moment you and Tom are
having are you still together are we
still together well you know what's to
be determined you guys are gonna have to
wait and see but on that journey of love
you know what I take risks and I'm so
proud of it I will always follow follow
my heart and you know what I'm grateful
I'm grateful for the energy that I bring
to relationships and opening my heart
and it's a positive thing in my my end
so I happen well look that's why people
love you because on a reality show you
are being real I feel you're being 100%
Darcy all the time I'm always Darcy and
Darcy's Darcy I've heard it before I'll
hear it again you know
Tom's gonna like maybe say a little bit
of what he wants to say but you know
what in the end I have a real heart I
want love just like everybody else and
you know when you know somebody for that
amount of time and you go on that
journey for love you know I'm deserving
of it and I'm not here to be made for a
fool so we'll see what happens
do you think Tom's made you for a fool I
wouldn't say that any at some moments
maybe at times yeah well I gotta tell
you Darcy I feel quite defensive of you
and I watched the show and I didn't like
for example that Tom's said to you if
you'd gone to gran canaria
oh then maybe he would have proposed
what did you think watching that well
honestly I did tell him you know I would
love and I was very grateful that he
proposed that opportunity but I just
felt at that moment in time the fact
that Stacey was going to Albania and
being there with her fiance it would be
a great time just to meet each other's
partners because mind you I had known
Tom for four years so was it like a
doobie kind of relationship so you know
I think there would have been plenty of
times for the Gran Canaria or something
else so he agreed upon it but you know
what I felt like he was holding it over
you a little bit like if we hadn't done
your trip I would have proposed right
and no one's gonna Dingle Darcy and
that's what I felt in that moment
one's gonna dingle Darcy I love that has
Tom said I love you he has said he loves
me but you will have to watch the next
couple shows to see what happens
so you know some people have been
accused of going on reality TV for fame
do you think that is any part of Tom's
motivation Tom's motivation is Tom's
motivation
I've known him for four years I trust
him and I just was being there on my own
journey and following my own heart and
when I love somebody I want to make sure
that it's like feeling right for me so
in the end I want to make sure his
intentions are real as well so you know
time will tell
time will tell when was the last time
you talked to him check out the night
next episode okay you know it's only a
few days away
oh what's that the last time you talked
not necessarily I'm pushing you down so
you know people really are captivated by
you for how emotional you are what do
you think when you're watching yourself
you know cry on TV and that kind of
thing like it does do the cameras take
you to another level what's it like it's
not the cameras it's it's an emotional
rollercoaster of being in that moment in
real time feeling you know you're
putting your life on the line you know
like loving giving your heart and
understanding when you when you feel in
that moment like something isn't right
like you get emotional you know and it
might rub someone else the wrong way
than the other person so I just I give
my heart and that's it and they could
say what they want but I'm sure you get
some critique online what do you have to
say to any of the haters any of the
haters you need to back off because I'm
very strong I love my life I love my
daughters I'm a full-time parent and
back off because you know DARS is gonna
be Darcy regardless and I will get mine
trust me we've seen your relationship
with your sister Stacy what's it been
like for you to watch those moments back
and where are you at now
you know what Stacy and I have a very
unique twin dynamic it's it's up and
down at times but you know what like any
sibling that's normal but we were very
close he almost can like read each
other's energies so regardless of
anything it's family
so if she's hurt I feel hurt and if I'm
hurt she feels at you but I know what
you guys see on the show is a little bit
of a ride here and there but you know
what it's okay we got it we handle it we
love to be on the ride with you Darcy
riding well it's been an unbelievable
season so far
looking back anything you would have
done differently and the only thing that
I think that I personally would be doing
differently was less tears which you
know what honestly you can't really
regret those because those are real but
I just want to make sure that people
understand where I'm coming from and
understanding that it's my real life and
it is what it is so you know what I will
always keep my eyes on the prize and if
the haters so the haters goodbye from
Darcy um your ex jesse has also come up
on the show how are you guys right now
do you still speak it off don't even
talk to him you still yappin his lips
I'm sure but I don't listen to it what
do you have to say to him if anything
nothing keep it in the light zip my lips
so we're gonna see what happens for you
and Tom people have noticed on social
media though that he's maybe been like
losing weight getting in shape and I and
I'm very proud of him for that that's
great you know we all go through own
transformations but when your ego gets
involved with the same aspects of it all
and it's questionable but you know what
I'm happy that he's done that for his
health but other than that we'll see
okay last question keep watching last
questions for you sometimes there's
drama amongst the couples like at the
reunions what do you think of the other
cup
watching the show who's genuine who's
headed for disaster I honestly really
feel connected to a lot of the cast
members this season which I've never
felt before but some are spicy some are
really real and some are genuine you
know you feel their energy and then you
know who to talk to you who taught you
so so you'll see you'll see the last
question what have you learned about
yourself doing this season I've learned
a lot about myself I'm 45 guys you
listen I've had two kids I've been
divorced I've been many relationships
you know Jessie hot like you know what
I'm not giving up no matter what I'm
gonna keep fighting love is on my heart
always but you know what I'll leave back
we'll see what happens
I I don't ever want to I don't ever want
you to leave my TV screen star see more
TV for you in the future
you never know keep watching
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]